>> ABSOLUTELY.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT YOU'VE
HERE'S THE CENTRING PLAY.
NYLANDE
ULLMARK.
WITH M ULLMARK.
BACK DOWN  AND A
THE LAST GAME AS YOU'VE SAID,
CAN'T FIND CARLO.
SPEZZA BACK TO THE
GOT A SHOT AWAY.
STOPPED BY ULLMARK.
HIS SHOT IS BLOCKED.
AND HE DIDN'T MAKE IT CLEANLY.
SPEZZA HAS IT.
HIS
>> BRODIE'S SINCE.
.927 WHEN IT COUNT.
HIS FIRST STAN FRONT.
THE ENTIRE LAST 2.5, 3 MINUTES.
THERE'S A NO LOOK PASS OFF THE
SKATES, THE REBOUND AND I
GREAT EFFORT RIGHT UNDERNEATHAW.
BBMATTHEWS ALONG THE
BOARDS.
SANDIN.
NYLANDER SHOOTING.STICK.
LOOK AT THE EFFORT.
OFF THE SKATE AND
MARCHAND.SCORES!
AND HE CURLS BACK, GOT HIMSELF A
LITTLE BIT OF A SEPARATION  COY.
NOW McAVOY!
AWAY!
GATHERED BY AN EMPTY
NET!